well more than half of all people with
active tuberculosis in the United States
were born outside the US now very few of
those people come into the United States
with active tuberculosis most of those
persons come in with a latent form of
tuberculosis that's not contagious
they're not sick we can identify those
people and we can treat them so it's a
very treatable condition in my view in
no measure is that a reason to keep
people from immigrating to the United
States persons who are coming here
should be screened for TB and treated if
they have it and then it won't be much
of a problem so I don't think it's a
reason to keep people out it's a very
easy mallet to beat people over the head
with to try to prevent immigration you
know immigrants are bad people who bring
diseases we've seen that before
in the United States and certainly in
the current climate there's a potential
for that again but but most persons who
come into the u.s. just have latent TB
infection as I said not contagious we
can identify them we can treat them and
they'll never get TB so I from my point
of view it would be really a tragedy if
that were used to drum up prejudice and
discrimination against people coming in
for perfectly legitimate reasons and
we've always depended on these people in
the United States
so people coming into United States with
active TB I said it's relatively
uncommon most of those persons don't
come legally if you try to legally
emigrate to the United States for
example you actually have to be screened
for tuberculosis in your home country so
if you're coming here you know in a
residence visa or something like that
you have to have an x-ray in your home
country and it's got to show that you
don't have contagious TB before you can
come in now some people are exempt from
that tourists for example don't get that
kind of screening and and students often
don't get that kind of screening but
people are coming here to live at least
do and we don't think there's too many
people who actually come into the United
States with active TB no in some parts
of the United States that is more of an
issue and that's particularly out west
California in the southwest where people
go back and forth across the border all
the time and that's not really the case
in New York because we're separated by
an ocean from most other borders but
California Arizona places like that it's
more of a problem there because people
go back and forth all the time and
they're I think the the solution is in
sort of cross border across government
cooperation for TB treatment